so we've got this second clip where he's
also making an argument let's actually
look at what he's saying okay yeah so
Jesus stopped so many things in the Old
Testament you don't want to accept that
that's that's that's your choice for
example why his disciples never killed
an apostate why his disciples never have
political power as soon as Christians
gained political power in the Roman
Empire they started doing these things
you didn't have the jurisdiction to do
so they didn't care the minority they
weren't in power no as soon as
Christians gain power within the Roman
Empire they applied the Old Testament
laws the New Testament it's not true
notified in the canon law do you know
are you there were the candidate I want
to talk about that so he's got he's got
literally yes no response he has no
response as you can see he's making this
argument he's making his argument why
did Jesus and his disciples not do
anything why did nothing happen Etc
you're forgetting the history is as if
you don't know the history Jesus well
not even in power before before before
we get to the history is I always find
it so interesting like that when
Christian people compare Muhammad was
Jesus yeah because Jesus for them is God
yes Muhammad for us is the final Prophet
yeah yeah so if you want to be fair why
don't you compare Allah with Jesus see
in their mind it's almost as if they've
humanized Jesus they've already it's
like a tacit admission that Jesus is not
actually a God he must be compared man
for man yeah with Muhammad so it's a
tacit admission okay here you've got
Jesus the man versus Muhammad the man
let's compare both careers but if you
guys believe as you do that Jesus is God
and it's part of the Trinity and so on
then surely surely he should be compared
with Allah because we believe in Allah
as our God that's the first thing the
second thing is this the point that
Daniel made was actually a very powerful
point because even if we do compare now
yes Jesus the historical figure the man
with
um
the main difference historically between
the two is that one of them was given
political power he has political power
he's a Statesman and the other one
according to their narrative is that he
was humiliated and killed on a cross so
you can't say well actually let's
compare his behavior with his behavior
because then when I come back and say
well in the Book of Revelation when he
comes back he's going to take engines
yeah yeah he's going to take Vengeance
yeah so I mean I mean so so they would
say no but then what they would do is
they did the shift they say well he was
a God so a God can take Vengeance if he
wants to so he becomes a god when he's
taking Vengeance yes and he's a man when
he's being humiliated very convenient
it's all so there's there's no winning
here yeah so that's one thing and then
the argument here which is that Daniel's
making and then they deny how could they
deny it because it's very very clear in
historical record if you know the early
history of Christianity anyone who's
studied the early history of
Christianity okay that they were first
to persecute a minority and then in 313
Christianity it was made into uh it was
allowed it was it was tolerated in the
Roman Empire and then when uh then when
Constantine became a Christian himself
he constituted it as uh the religion of
the Empire and then after that near the
5th Century like the end of the fourth
Century you had theodosius and stuff
which by force you know he he insisted
on certain theological things and if any
forget about non-pager pagans or
something like that some non-christians
if you didn't believe in Nicene uh
Constantinople Constantinople type
Christianity then you could be
persecuted physically for that and this
is well known historical record and then
you have a bloody history of of
Christianity you have the Crusades say
you have the Crusades I mean how can
these people how can Robert Spencer okay
and Rasheed hamami sit there and speak
as if they are ignorant they're not
ignorant by the way of the Crusades he's
not ignorant because I've seen uh what's
his name Robert Spencer speak to Javad
uh uh I can't remember hash me yes and
he had a debate with him yeah and and in
that debate he he he he quoted well he
admitted that there have been people who
have uh effectively uh who who have been
inspired by Biblical verses to do
violence he admitted that point yes so
um because you have something called the
papal Bulls and the paper Bulls are
these they're authoritative uh you know
proclamations by the popes yes okay and
and there were paper Bulls from Urban II
as you know yeah you know in 1095 in the
First Crusade when when they came and
they were reconquesting the according to
them I mean the whole initial concept of
the Crusades or religiously motivated
wolves Justified religiously motivated
other people bought by the way it's not
just because all the things they
mentioned in that thing yeah yeah
um slavery this that all that stuff the
machine gun tactics yes all of that you
have people Bulls like for example the
people bull off Nicholas V yes now the
people bull of Nicholas V
uh Justified or gave to the religious
justification for slavery yeah so all of
these things having been said you can't
actually make an argument and I was very
frustrated a lot of the Christians some
of them yeah and I'm gonna challenge
this now some of the Christians were
saying well Jake and Daniel didn't
understand
um the Old Testament and the sanctuary
actually I think both of them understand
Christianity more than most of the
Christians do yes they've studied it on
an academic level and moreover number
two there's the second point if you
really think about it right you've got
you've got Christianity that's being
pushed here which is that there's a new
covenant and that there's no there's no
requirement for a law okay that's what's
being said so that Jesus as he mentioned
in the beginning Rashida said that he
stopped he means to say he abrogated he
don't want to say the word he abrogated
all that was required in the Old
Testament even though the exact opposite
is mentioned in the bible yeah but I'm
not here to do away with the law the
Prophet come to affirm them but put that
to the side
if you if you look at it and the
secondary source scholarly material
people like James Dunn EP Sanders others
like you can look at this in the
scholarly Works non-muslims have written
about this the idea that actually it was
Paul himself Paul who in the early
Christianity changed Christianity in a
manner that would make it seem as if all
you need to do is believe in the
crucifixion Resurrection this story and
you don't you have to you can forego the
Old Testament rules this is not
something which the early Christians
believe and the biggest tension that you
can find in the Bible is between Paul
and James and people don't know who
James is James according to the biblical
narrative is meant to be the brother of
Jesus Christ yes okay brother how
because they believe Joseph the
carpenter had another you know uh a son
which is not through Mary obviously a
lot of them do believe In Perpetual
virginity and stuff I'm not going to get
into the doctrine but the idea is that
they believe in James now James you can
see a clear
you can see a clear because a conflict
between him and Paul
and in that conflict
Paul is effectively trying to argue
against the law especially circumcision
the book of Acts you can see his arguing
against these kind of things and Paul is
saying uh be with the Jew be a Jew with
the Jew and the Gentile with the
Gentiles be pragmatic but the point is
is that there's nothing definitively to
show in early Christianity that this
movement away from the Old Testament
laws was definitive as they want to be
make out to be Paul seems to be
spearheading this process and that is
clearly in the historical record clearly
it's been mentioned by Scholars of
Christianity non-muslim Scholars of
Christianity even Martin Luther mentions
it and I can read quotations I mean
maybe since we're doing this video I can
I'll read a quotation from Martin Martin
Luther who who's as you know we're
talking about Martin Luther not Martin
Luther King Martin Luther the the who
he's named after yeah Martin Luther is
the uh in many ways the one who started
the Protestant Reformation he says the
following he says
though this Epistle of James was
rejected by this because someone say a
responding said well reject it because
it wasn't made into and this is another
question who decides what books go into
the Bible I don't even want to go
athanasius decided it it wasn't through
a council astonacius decided it and what
books go into New Testament this is
however this is this is what uh this is
what Martin Luther saying he's saying
though the um though this Epistle of
James was rejected by the ancient
ancients I praise and consider it a good
book to State my own opinion about it
without prejudice to anyone I do regard
it as the writing of an apostle and my
reasons uh follow in the first place is
flatly against Paul and all the rest of
scripture in ascribing justification to
Works in a word he warned against those
who relied on faith without works but
was unequal to task in spirit though
inwards uh thought sorry and words
therefore I will not have him in my
Bible
to be numbered among the true Chief
books though I would not thereby prevent
anyone from including or extolling him
as he pleases for there are otherwise
many good sayings in him so basically
note that he understands this idea of
justification the justification by
faithful solofide which was promoted in
Christianity this this idea is a poor
line idea okay and this is something
which is clear
why then would we throw away the Old
Testament and throw in the Box even if
by the way let's not throw away the Old
Testament by the boss let's just stick
to the New Testament because they made
it seem as if there's nothing in the New
Testament there's nothing in the New
Testament so let me just read this
imagine if this this particular thing
was in the in the Quran okay this is the
Book of Luke yeah
and this is something which is meant to
have said Jesus has said yeah I have I
have come to bring fire on Earth
and how I wish
it were already kindled but I have a
baptism to undergo and what I can what
constraint am I under it it is completed
do you think I came to bring peace on
Earth
Jesus
no I tell you about division for now
there will be five in one family divided
against each other three against two and
two against three
they will be divided father against son
son against father mother against
daughter and daughter against mother
mother-in-law against daughter-in-law
and daughter-in-law against
mother-in-law now what are we talking
about here this is the New Testament
don't make it as if the New Testament is
a pacifist book
so the the thing is this is that they're
coming across as if you've got violence
that the whole argument against the
slams you've got violence you've got
violence in your books and this is your
narrative by the way this is these
aren't the things that we believe about
Jesus yeah this is from your narrative
yeah okay of of Jesus the the point
they're making which is that Islam is
Fault effectively don't put it this way
about this it's a screwed us to say look
the reason why we're not Muslim is or
the greatest challenge that we have
against Islam is this location of
violence yeah they mentioned violence
okay so what so what so what you're so
you're a Christian you're throwing
stones from glass houses that's what it
is that's essentially what you're doing
it's absolutely shocking and that's why
initially in the beginning I think it
was a very good point that Daniel made
who are we debating right now what are
we discussing with are we discussing
with atheists yes because you're coming
across you're coming across as if you're
none the wiser to these verses in the
Bible yeah you have no clue about these
verses in the Bible yeah okay and both
of you who uh you know put yourselves
across as you know a Christian
Representatives as Christian essentially
you know speakers okay public speakers
representing the Christians you don't
know what's in the Bible you don't know
that yeah and that was one of the main
comments that people had is that these
guys could not defend the Bible yeah bro
you can't throw the Bible under the bus
not just the Bible is they had they had
insufficient knowledge of Christianity
yes yes well Jake and Daniel had more
knowledge of Christianity and this is
evidence in the fact that Jake was
quizzing uh Robert Spencer who's meant
to be more knowledgeable in this matter
yeah yeah about the Trinity and he said
that namely someone the first 300 years
that talked about Trinity right and by
that obviously Jake means the co-equal
and co-eternal yes three persons of the
Trinity yes and this is and then you
mentioned basil who is one of the
cappadocian like we're talking about
what the time of the cappadocian fathers
is like late 300s yeah that's not in the
first 300 years yeah yeah that's after
the fact so you've given up a timeline
of 300 years and you're giving someone
400 years later so you're you're using
him okay you're using him in order to
make the point that all three uh persons
of the godhead are
which is exactly the nicerian
Constantinople in Creed which is not
which is not what happened and then he
mentions I don't know if it's Ignatius
or one of the treasures all these Church
fathers that is mentioned all of them
believe in subordination all of them
believed in subordinationism they
believed that the father was more
powerful the son the Holy Spirit yeah so
when it came to the key matters when did
they become co-equal then exactly
so that when it came to the key tenants
and the key Credo implications there's
no doubt in my mind they they try to
avoid that like her barge poll they used
to they have to because they're weak
here they don't wanna they don't want to
if it was a proper debate about
Christianity in Islam why not debate
Trinity the the Divinity look there's
two things yeah that really separate
Muslims and Christians yes number one
thank you yes but Trinity the Trinity
yes all right so the idea of is Jesus
God this is why don't we start with that
and then number two the prophet of the
Prophet if you if you resolve those
areas there's no difference between
commonalities if you resolve those two
Muslims and effectively we believe in
the same thing
the point is is you guys were too scared
to engage with that they as soon as Jake
started speaking about Trinity he didn't
want to engage because you cannot
because your belief and and the modern
day Christian belief that the Father the
Son and the Holy Spirit are co-eternal
yes okay we've all been there and they
are co-equal yeah okay that they are
equally God yes okay this is nonsensical
to the idea of monotheism it is against
monotheism yes absolutely okay and you
cannot be as Christians claim you cannot
claim to be a monotheist okay and and
claim to and believe in this idea of the
Trinity it's like a square circle I
think what you've done here is right I
think we've we've looked at some of the
things here this Rasheed guy honestly
he's he's ended his career before he
could even start yeah why stars in the
English-speaking language against people
like Daniel and Jake frankitella why
would you start with the Muslim he's one
of the top guys why would you start it's
like going as in a boxing ring and the
first fight you want to have the issue
is the issue is clearly you've got
knocked out from anymore no one wants
you to Ever represent them again you are
fin
you are finished you're absolutely done
you can go back to speaking in the
arabic speaking world where a few cops
will clap for you in arabic speaking or
even they don't like you but it's done
now for you in the English-speaking
World you've been vomited out very very
quickly we don't like we don't like it
the Christians don't like it the English
don't like it the Americans don't like
it even even the Moroccans don't like it
I mean your own people don't like it
you're humiliated yourself in your
nation yes I mean no his nation is free
from him of course Allah sent Jake he's
this guy he is this is an amazing Point
Allah sent Jake yeah to show because
Morocco is one of the best for me he's
one of the most beautiful countries to
go to the people are fantastic people
excellent the culture is brilliant you
have a river and and they're they're
they're very tolerant people you have
it's it's amazing because if you were to
look at him someone who's got the Arabic
language someone who can say and he was
trying to attack him about God what did
you call what he's wearing the clothing
I mean let's do a poll in Morocco yeah
and let's see what the Moroccans have to
say about this and the guy's wearing a
suit yeah I mean he's wearing a suit and
he's talking about why is why is he
wearing this as Moroccan clothes why are
you wearing my clothes like who the who
are you you're in his country buff you
are in his country what are you talking
about man be quiet you should be
counting you know this does this and I
think we should end on this yeah this
reminds of an eye of the Quran
they deny they they they turned away
they disbelieved in the truth when it
came to them so they are in a confused
State they are confused they are
confused they're confused
we'll see you next time